now some of this is an inference so you
know take it with a grain of salt but I
would argue that even a 10% chance of
getting your life absolutely destroyed
in divorce is still pretty risky we all
know that even amongst religious couples
the divorce rate is still 25 35 45% and
what happens is we go back and forth
with the tradcons and they'll say oh
well it's lower than you guys are saying
you're doom and gloomer and what I
typically see them do is manipulate the
stats now how do they do that if the
average age of divorce is 46 I would
argue you're not painting a full picture
by using the stats of men in their 20s
and 30s I know many men that were very
happily married in their 20s and 30s
before getting their lives absolutely
destroyed in their 40s and 50s a more
honest answer would be surveying the men
in their 60s and 70s what their opinion
is on marriage